[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir pourquoi
cette entreprise un homme seul qui
n'engageait ne représente que lui même
et qui est dépourvu de tout moyen
matériel dans une campagne où l'argent
est les parties vont jouer un rôle
prépondérant
on dira que ma candidature est marginal
voire qu'elle est fantaisiste
vous en jugerez par vous même au cours
de cette campagne qui intervient dans
une situation où la fantaisie n'est pas
de mise ce soir nous allons réfléchir
ensemble sur notre temps et sur notre
pays dans cette crise qui le secoue et
qui nous menacent jeudi réfléchir car il
ne s'agit pas pour moi de présenter un
programme ou de formuler des promesses
mais bien de poser la question
essentielle celle qui est au centre de
tout et qui commande tout l'essentiel
c'est l'état l'essentiel c'est la
constitution qui doit donner à l'état
les moyens de l'indépendance de la
stabilité et de la continuité car
aujourd'hui plus que jamais voici que
tout est remis en question
non seulement le maintien au pouvoir du
parti du dr mais la vème république
non seulement la cinquième république
mais l'état tout entier
la disparition brutale du président de
la république l'a montré notre système
institutionnel ne peut fonctionner que
dans la mesure où le chef de l'état
contraint d'abandonner le pouvoir peut
désigner son successeur
ce choix n'a pas été fait par le
président pompidou et voici l'état livré
aux mains des parties voici les parties
divisées en des querelles de clans voici
les clans en proie à toutes les
querelles
telle est la situation de l'ancienne
majorité aujourd'hui divisée par trois
candidatures telle est la situation de
l'état géré par un gouvernement ruiné
par ses contradictions il n'y a plus
d'état
quand des clans se contente de gérer une
administration il n'y a plus d'état
quand un président intérimaire sort de
sa fonction d'arbitré pour se livrer à
des considérations politiques
personnelles cette situation est
dangereuse parce qu'elle survient à un
moment où la société française est
confrontée à une crise redoutable comme
l'ont montré les longs et durs conflits
sociaux de ces dernières semaines
cette situation est dangereuse parce
qu'elle intervient au moment même où la
nation française est placé devant des
choix décisifs dans la conduite de ses
relations avec les autres nations
et avec les empires
et c'est à ce moment précis que les
hommes d'état deviennent des hommes deux
parties et qu'ils remettent à plus tard
les mesures qui s'imposent pour ne
penser qu'à leurs querelles partisanes
comme si la vie s'arrêtait pendant la
campagne électorale
comme si les prix cessaient de monter
comme si chaque citoyenne était plus
confrontés à ces problèmes de travail
d'emploi de transport ou de vie
familiale ainsi chacun de nous et prouve
profondément la crise de l'état par la
faute d'institutions qui n'ont pas su
lui donner les moyens de la continuité
quelles que soient les circonstances et
aussi grave soit elle
ainsi va la vie quotidienne qui est
cruellement affectés par cette carence
de l'état
ainsi va la vie de la nation dont
l'avenir est compromis
depuis plusieurs mois
la france est l'objet de pressions voire
de menaces ou de chantage pour qu'elle
accepte de rentrer sous la protection
américaine
jusqu'à maintenant la france avait tenu
bon en dépit de quelques ambiguïtés
jusqu'à présent la france avait réussi à
préserver son indépendance et à conduire
librement sa diplomatie
et voici soudain que tout est remis en
question à cause de cette rupture dans
la continuité de l'état qui menace
gravement l'avenir de la nation
car c'est au moment même où la
permanence du projet était essentielle
c'est au moment même où la fermeté était
indispensable que tout se fige dans la
tente des résultats de l'élection
présidentielle alors que la situation
impose le choix
la décision et l'action car il faut bien
voir que les autres nations n'attendront
pas le résultat des élections pour agir
au contraire certes elle s'empresse de
saisir l'occasion pour tenter de faire
rentrer la france dans le rang personne
n'a oublié le jour même des obsèques du
président de la république
la scandaleuse opération de propagande
menée par le président nixon en faveur
de sa politique impérialiste
intervention d'une puissance étrangère
luttes de clans qui morcellent et
ruinent l'état affrontements des partis
et division des français
immobilisme dans tous les domaines alors
qu'il faudrait agir
tels sont aujourd'hui les conséquences
d'une de cette absence de l'état que
chacun ne peut manquer de ressentir
telle est notre présent et nous verrons
que l'avenir paraît encore moins assuré
nous en reparlerons dès mardi prochain
[Musique]